this is a 3D printer on a drone in fact
it's the First Time 3D printing like
this has ever been achieved by a free
flying robot
a group of scientists and Engineers were
inspired by bees and wasps who worked
together to deposit material and create
large yet intricate structures
they envisioned a future where swarms of
drones like these could be used to build
houses or Emergency Shelters in remote
areas but effectively combining 3D
printing technology with flying robots
was an enormous challenge
one of the biggest problems was accuracy
to ensure a tall structure is stable
each layer needs to Overlay precisely
onto the one below
so the researchers used scanning drones
which fly in with a camera and scan
everything that's been printed so far
this information can then guide the
printing drones to exactly the right
spot
getting them to stay in the right spot
was also tricky drones tend to drift
during flight especially Outdoors
so the team created a print head that
adjusts its position to compensate for
the movement of the Drone this results
in millimeter scale precision and
intricate filigree-like printing this
drone is printing with an expanding foam
Which is less predictable to print with
but very lightweight in fact every
element on the Drone needed to be as
light as possible to save energy
the team even created a new cement-like
material that could be carried by the
Drone printed while soft which would
then Harden
inspired by the bees and wasps the
researchers also wanted to make sure the
drones could work together efficiently
they designed them to be semi-autonomous
able to adapt to changes as they're
building during this test of a scaled up
build the team virtually tracked the
drone's paths to show how a group could
efficiently print large structures
the idea of 3D printing a house is one
that's already been put into practice
with ground-based printers
but the team think that the aerial
printers could be useful in less
accessible places like in mountains or
disaster zones or they could be used for
repairing things like facades pylons or
pipelines without the need to build
scaffolding
aerial printing is also scalable you
don't need a printer bigger than the
thing you're building when you have a
team of smaller flying printers
the hope is that 3D printing could be a
more environmentally friendly
alternative to traditional construction
methods and printing with drones
inspired by the natural world could be
an important part of making construction
greener
[Music]